waldorf education is based on the
principles of anthroposophy by Rudolf
Steiner Steiner founded the first school
in 1919 Stuttgart Germany to educate the
children of the factory workers from the
Waldorf Astoria zigaretten fabric ends
the name all kids
independent of social status or talent
received the same instruction which made
the school a pioneer of social justice
in education the goal of a Waldorf
education is to develop free but morally
responsible individuals equipped with a
high degree of social competence and
creative capabilities factual knowledge
homework and test scores receive less
attention storytelling and
experimentation are the main method of
instruction over the 12-year curriculum
students learn math literature history
and science as well as a wide variety of
hearts and hands-on skills
elementary students paint knit weave and
sculpt with wax older ones make patterns
books pottery
and sculpting stone everybody learns to
do music first I'll play the flute then
some play string instruments and others
join the choir students play non
competitive games and learn to dance you
rythme they do organic farming and learn
two foreign languages which in the first
years are taught through songs
storytelling and conversations in grade
8 and 12 the entire class develops a
classical drama which they perform in
front of their parents and Friends
walled-off uses a unique project based
approach to almost all main academic
subjects instead of repetitive schedules
a specific subject such as history math
science or even gardening dominates the
first two hours in the morning for a
period of four to six weeks after that a
new subject gets the main focus
Steinar also invented an experiential
approach to science whereby students
observe and later describe scientific
concepts in their own words and drawings
rather than learning about them in a
textbook first waldorf schools therefore
consider computers useful to children
only in their teens after they have
mastered fundamental time-honored ways
of discovering information and learning
in the spirit of personal development
and empathy competition and grades are
being avoided teachers instead assess
the students individual growth of
character test scores and grades are
only slowly introduced to older students
as they prepare for college and entrance
exams today there are over a thousand
waldorf schools in sixty countries
making it one of the largest independent
school movements Waldorf has become a
recognized educational theory in Europe
and it's schools have received state
funding famous walled-off parents
include Clint Eastwood Lenny Kravitz the
Forbes family and many parents from
Silicon Valley's tech sector
despite Steiners critical view of
technology and mass media Steve Jobs
once told a tech journalist who asked
whether his children liked the new iPad
that they haven't used it and continued
we limit how much technology our kids
use at home acclaimed psychiatrist
William Glasser famously said that we
learned 10% of what we read 20% of what
we hear 30% of what we see but 80% of
what we experienced one could argue that
despite their low-tech approach the
experimental learning method of waldorf
education is exceptionally contemporary
what do you think please share your
thoughts in the comments below